it was six in the morning and still dark
when seven thousand nurses walked off
the job at two private New York
hospitals but it wasn't unexpected
nurses have been negotiating for four
months now
management offered them pay increases
amounting to more than 18 percent over
the next three years but the nurses say
this is not about money it's about safe
Staffing and they have the support of
the city's labor groups
and we are going to be with them today
and as long as it takes to get a fair
contract that they deserve you cannot
talk about patient care without talking
about how you take care of and how you
listen to the people who provide patient
care today yeah here at Mount Sinai
they've canceled elective surgeries and
moved some babies out of the neonatal
Intensive Care Unit to other hospitals
in anticipation of the service
disruptions management has called the
nurses actions Reckless but the nurses
say they're the ones looking out for
patient safety nurses say they are
routinely asked to care for more
patients than is safe sometimes up to 20
per nurse in emergency rooms where a
limit of three is recommended but
California is the only state that
mandates nurse-to-patient ratios in a
year and a half
our vacancy balloon to 550. that is what
is reckless nurses say the Staffing
shortages started even before the
coronavirus pandemic when they were
hailed as Heroes on the front line with
City hospitals crowded with sick and
dying patients many nurses put others
Health before their own the stress they
say is causing many to leave their jobs
seven other hospitals have come to
agreements in the last week but there
appears to be public support for the
remaining holdouts should just get that
money they deserve it every cent every
dollar New York's Governor has called on
both sides to agree to binding
arbitration to minimize service
disruptions the nurses say that without
guarantees on Staffing levels the crisis
will only get worse for them and the
patients they care for Kristen salumi Al
Jazeera New York